so you've been on this we're all now hey
everybody what's going on Toby Turner
here play here Beth here just another
corner hey sweet right now welcome to
one in melee today Toby Turner he
created this game mine the diamond which
is available for iOS I did it's free and
it's very frustrating you'll hate it for
a long time you might eventually enjoy
it but only when you're away from it
only best music ever buy them thank you
my diamond mine it's amazing it's a
parody of my own song which is very
original and the Perisher perfect how
the song is more expensive than the game
free today so I thought because indie
game darling we play with my favorite
indie games braid which you've never
played I've never played it it should
have played to me and it was cool and
now it's so cool it's always cool very
happy Deb sat down in here yes yes it's
always cool it's always kind of limbo
knee yeah it's very it is kind of limbo
limbo limbo is your little dude here and
but yeah so so when how did you come up
with the idea for mine the diamond well
I mean flappy bird came out and
everyone's like well let's make a flappy
bird I was a gay let's do like a
vertical flappy bird but I would I have
a theme song and tell us people to tell
people to download it and write we
eventually you know we did that yes but
we made this other game before that
called Tobuscus avengers wizards which
is like it takes a time what was it
called
Tobuscus adventures was Tobuscus
adventures with wheats and again it was
these adventures wizard wizard suppose
wizards so i'm that's it's just the
cartoon series i had to us by the way
we've done like 16 pounds of meth before
we started you know I'm a wing nerd I
like to wait things do you have an
energy drink cuz I actually I think I'm
overcompensating for my lack of it okay
that's okay that's okay don't worry
don't worry it's all good
Tobuscus adventures wizards with yet
first game that was a person we raised a
lot of money for it
we promised it'd be out two months after
we started developing it okay a year and
a half later everyone's very mad and
thought I ran away but we had actually
gone over the budget and it just took
way too freaking long okay it's fun now
and you know I I so many things about I
was like I hate this I hate this I hate
this remove that and then we fixed it
it's awesome sucks as little as possible
and Joe what were the things
things that you hated about it like one
of the one of monsters like the wind
wizard he doesn't hurt you doesn't do
anything he just blows your spell's off
you're quick bar so you have to put your
spell's back on your quick bar and
that's all I guess
so let's instead of chips just like a
frustrating thing my way doing what our
developers lit they like to frustrate
yes feel the pain they feel that's true
making making exactly that's hilarious
so in this game I don't know you've
never played braid braid is we just kind
of skipped over the story here's what
gets me about braid braid is a game
where this guy and yets gonna story is
kind all dress
wait you're well-dressed wilderness
gorgeous game gorgeous game but there's
a there's a basically you've done
something bad you were in love with a
woman while you're saying that I needed
sweet to where here see we got to we
wouldn't we keep talking all listen and
yes you multitask multitask live live
streaming on on twitch.tv slash Team
Coco
oh you guys are calculating how fast
free coconut water oh yeah coconut milk
that's all anything coconut did anything
cook are you into them yeah anyways okay
so and then what hashtag or what do you
guys have yeah yeah yeah let's do a
hashtag let's do a hashtag Monday melee
monday melee it does this guy doesn't go
candy but here's the great part about
this game so it's all about it's all of
the idea is it's all about time it's
awesome and instead of dying like what
happens it you can just rewind right
okay so like a 2d Prince of Persia yes
that's a good way of putting yeah two
days possibly better dress yeah but much
better dressed Prince of Persia less
sand
exactly exactly uh awful sick coconuts
like them young wait so all right so you
did sort of uh skis adventure wizards
that happened then you were like let's
take out all the past forever right
slowly like like the wizard no no did
not take out the bad stuff because
taking it out would cost like fifty
thousand dollars whoa yeah yeah for
every little change that's in crazy
because like they're so far in the
development so instead I just had to
make fun of it so in and the game itself
the wizard introduces the wind wizard
like the good Wizards on your side yeah
he's like whoa what are those guys do
he's like they just blow your spell's up
your quick bomb knowing that's awesome
so you just make fun of like their
decisions and it made it much better and
I feel like fans liked it too when when
when you acknowledge what now no
absolutely that's what they have a
company that's all whole thing about
ecology is being naughty in series yeah
yeah yeah don't take it there's more we
saw that you saw a terminator last night
actually Oh Genesis was it the premiere
it was actually really really good right
because it's so funny so when you see
the commercial they had all the lines
that were like you know that I'll be
back yeah if you want to live like
that's too maybe too much but they just
included all over the core like the
whole movie is just well paced and like
we watched it with like the cast
everything oh my god that's awesome Seok
was aren't either
mmm-hmm oh my god yeah so we did it we
did a promotion with him where he says
bless your face it pushes me into a time
vortex oh my god that's awesome who's
amazing how is she what's one thing they
surprised you about Schwarzenegger in
person oh well I mean he's very nice and
he's very you know not surprised I mean
no no Achilles right he's great but like
he's not full of himself he's just very
calm and friendly to everybody make sure
to her what vocab word okay yeah yeah
humble means college campus though WB
campus oh like a college kid yeah
absolutely
it is definitely very ecology but what
surprised me about I mean so when I met
him he had some lines to learn if he
hadn't seen him yet he had like two
paragraphs he's like got it and they
just did it first thing
whoa hilarious he's really professional
he's a professional
he should be a professional actor should
keep doing this yeah exactly
oh wait okay so mine the diamond explain
to people what it is you have never
played mine the diamond oh it's very
very exciting so you tap on the screen
and then your guy is kinetically gonna
die you try to avoid these death rocks
and harvest these diamonds to avoid that
inevitable death yeah as long as you can
and then you dig through the entire
planet to the dirt to the stone to the
obsidian stone dirt and then you come
out the other side of the planet go into
the sky is that so much bird oh my god
and then you go into space well then you
go to the moon then you go through the
moon they go the Sun
skin melts off and you're just skeleton
where are you serious up TZ oh my god
wait can you play you have it yeah
played a song I want people to hear the
song this mom told me played as loudly
as it can be it's loud you can put it
right up next to the mic okay it's so
silly
go back on the dab on the people you
don't know to get mine the damn on find
a random phone download mine the diamond
before reporting phone the lost and
found a diamond that amazing amazing
that's incredible I think you did you
sing that song no that's you of course
oh my god I do everything
oh my god you have to you have to so
what what are you working on now are you
working on to the game what are you
working yes we're working love people's
minds we're working on another game that
is where you get you join a room of five
other people and it gives you three
letters for em one you can make up an
acronym oh and the best acronym you vote
basically then round 2 is like more it's
an acronym again guys be right there
got it yeah yeah so you make up your own
acronym I'm stupid I mean any party
t-shirts fine now you'll make you much
smarter with our game anyway Hajime oh I
see so then it's kind of like acronym
battle sure yeah
acronym kind of like that yeah yeah well
what is that gonna battle is it the
person no that's just a thing I just
said that oh that's perfect that could
be the name of it okay you know or accra
war after war Cup that's pretty cool
yeah I don't know but anyways it's
coming out in like two months but it's
not I think it's gonna be the best cuz
it makes you think about words and yeah
for sure funny sentences it makes people
be funny that want to share it yeah you
are dying again I know let's see there's
no dying this game you just keep her
winding so here's the thing so you have
to kind of jump I'm gonna give me I'm
giving you the control here in a minute
just so you know good everywhere look at
then everyone will see what I am capable
of no your keep a little great things
you've already made mine the diamond
what else
no I don't need to step it any further
oh my god I mean I feel okay so when
Leonardo Divinci came up with like the
theory of gravity
was he like I need to come up with
something else no yeah wait yeah I guess
he was yeah but no uh I don't know it's
it's I want to just make a game all the
time so I have so many ideas but they're
expensive Derek so and I was able to
make them profitable I just wanna met
you know it's probably people in the day
I don't do it obviously obviously I'm an
idiot
wait so take us from the process of
against you have an idea for people out
there one okay I mean okay so if you
want to make a game you have to learn it
all yourself which is gonna suck for you
which is gonna step on for wait for your
first game did you have you did it all
yourself
we found a team we found it and then I
Craigslist what are we talking about
uh y-you know I asked a friend usually
and he was it voter listed this team
phoned a friend like and he was exactly
yeah I called him on the phone okay uh I
got five seconds ago okay they found
this is perfect actually games the game
companies called game mechanics okay I
have a character so I'm a cartoon to my
C's adventures the character's name is
Gabe I call him Gabe osseous Gabe boss
needs like it's Gabe
Ausmus there's a pause so in game
mechanics like mechanics anyways so you
know we have an idea we got this team I
wanted to draw symbols to cast spells oh
yeah okay here's what you do have an
idea yeah make a video you know what
you're passionate enough about it yes
make a video first you need the pass
here like if you're not perishable
you're not gonna happen either but I'm
but you make a video recording yourself
being super passionate get a dawn that
you know calls you out for this ask for
money okay and then make the video
what's your dog in you and then post it
online and got hundreds of thousands of
dollars
gotta give them to a company and hope
that they make the game and don't suck
okay if you have to leap of faith a
little bit oh my god I didn't lock ball
game weird patrol oh is it gonna let me
do this
[Music]
okay so passion dog video online then
what I mean then you start so panic the
panic so they start writing the game so
you said you say it yes right so so
right it's like I was like I want to
draw symbols to cast spells to kill
zombies because everybody loves killing
zombies everybody loves killing their
fun anyway so then they started working
on the engine I kind of wrote the story
cuz there are eight like animated
cutscenes and like you know uh like an
hour of voice so it's a lot because I
recorded at all my house oh my god I
could add as much as I want it but and
then they're putting stuff in the wrong
places cuz it's just so complicated
unless you're like living at the office
with these people yeah and I was
shooting you know a ton of YouTube
videos yeah yeah
so then I cut that out I just focused
only on the guy had to for you know a
couple months that's crazy it's nice now
so then I come away so then it kind of
and then you went you go through test
six months after six after six months of
them just doing stuff on there because I
was you know I had to work on my YouTube
stuff way to do it you have to be there
but I was like oh yeah we'll get it to a
place where then we'll be ready for your
feedback okay so then we look at it and
though they had made this game and like
well a lot of this stuff like I don't
why is that there no I mean you know we
just wanted to take some take liberties
don't take any liberties man save
liberties oh I don't know I just say we
have a mind meld look at our shoes we
all have great kings I do American flag
shoes that's right right made in China
in China
[Laughter]
all right you play this game here's how
you play right X rewinds and then just
kill the bad guys I think you want to
get up that and get that key and then
they'll get a wine back okay all right
do you okay see you but I'm asking
questions what am i doing right now do
you want to kill this thing oh yeah oh
yeah oh my god or what just Roy just for
wine just don't have to stress no no
there's no stress no stress
yeah I'm really relaxed so you make the
game six months go by they may screw it
up you go back to it's a um please
unscrew it and then and then it comes
out that what happened within you
yeah it's got magic Julian green magic
oh there's a pretty yeah there's
definitely a now shove it in or no
uh-huh how do you get up panicked Oh was
I supposed to go up I think so oh boy
Abner don't ask us to unlock the game I
knew it oh yeah I knew it ball you got
it you big dinosaur yeah you're extinct
I thought you guys knew you have to do
so you let me see let me see I'll try to
unlock it skip to the next all right so
you have a great youtube channel talk to
people about our youtube day your you to
show my you to my googles I don't have a
nice camera or logo dang that's right
step on my head like darish or a lovely
wonderful bathtub chant looks at the
things in there and what do you do
exactly
can we go fullscreen on us she kills
people rude people murders yeah I just
everything's just low production it's
possible always and not always just full
you know yeah I would ramble for 10
minutes and sometimes there's like a
good 30 seconds in there that you're
like hey how did you get started how did
you decide you want to start doing
YouTube videos you know I just my mom
was like you want to be a dentist and I
was like oh when I started going to
dentistry school cuz that nice teeth
because what races really yeah I nice
you're gonna be a dentist
yes thinking about it is a high school
play and she's like you were really good
in that play college and like it you
know it was not as fun as I thought and
then I started instead making making
videos right right trying to get as many
views as possible and what was your
first video you made I mean well the
first one that I that I really made him
and put up to try to get views was his
like it's like pork pork coke on a
report coconut raw pork and see what
happens it was the earth legend that
worms would come out of it so like what
so I cut to black and then I made rice I
gotta set rice chunks on the pork and I
was like oh that that was word that's
disgusting and he got a million views
and nothing man wait so did anything
happen when you put the nothing neither
no no I come on and you know so audible
like like at the time they're like oh he
wouldn't be
lying about that woody so just cut his
black and then cut back in those rice
chips got a million views which at that
time was like thousands a couple
thousand dollars rats and mice e because
Metacafe was just paying way too much
right anyways so yeah and then I was
like a comedy it's my comedy stuff
instead of you know urban legend
yeah for me but I want you to make well
then so is that was her pressure second
video because it's like dude you poured
the thing and you had all these views
and now it's like well how do you follow
up the pork video how do you do port you
do pork I mean what do you do
no one was out no one was hoping for
more pork I was so feeling more blood I
know I know you are but luckily for -
searching pork videos does do things
come out I actually did that's actually
I think this probably titles about like
I ask the questions you guys question
the title it's not like they're kind of
like an amateur but um oh God
yeah that's linked to the clip going to
the clip so wait we had to go we were
signed to the wrong thing and I we
didn't have the full thing so I'm just
gonna beat this level again very quick
in the new to play nice so sorry keep
going
so for to you know you don't know what
to do you're having a crisis how do i
how do i do I've done pork how do i do
pull so at that point I was like I think
I'm sure to do something funny instead
and then I so I made a thing called do I
don't know me there was a long time ago
I made this video called love buggies
that I liked it was so funny and I ended
up taking it down it's somewhere online
but oh we use the BBQ sauna let's get it
on song okay and these two shopping
carts go on a date okay and then then it
gets very inappropriate
whoa I like it you know you can stack
shopping cart before you're making
shopping cart I mean yeah you could you
know bring it down to that and instead
of the art oh [ __ ]
oh hey there's our horn we're in the
pizza man you know what I'm saying
there's a lot of motivation there behind
the plumber laying the pipe oh I see oh
and they stack so you must need a little
wd-40 some shopping carts hello Saturday
night that's hilarious
and then it
just kind of exploded from them slowly
yeah it really really took out when I
started playing video games yeah I post
you know clip every day for years yeah
and you know every day for years videos
a day for you wow that's crazy yeah yeah
no that was just my gaming channel if I
mentioned my blog channel was like one a
day of a vlog Wow and then you know what
a week of my on my main channel that's
amazing
that's crazy and yeah and so when you
sign but it's yeah I do I see I didn't
sleep through things and I was like I
should probably do that so I've been
sleeping more and I you know not that
I'm figuring out like where I'm gonna be
doing more of the gaming stuff and like
I because I'm gonna do you know twitch
streaming but my internet for minutes I
know I just got fast internet in my
house so I'm just gonna I'm just getting
into twitching just myself but yeah here
like on the lot we have amazing internet
which it's what how many how many tera
gigawatts is it I think it's at least
tachyon reverses like all or at pleurisy
or 80 of okay so it's busy like it's
based like 10 or 12 flim flam's like ham
and cheese yeah zig zag clip so the arse
is action of 30 up now so you got okay
this is a so this is great so somebody
sign the contract I didn't sign it yeah
so we asked how much it would cost for
Time Warner to give me Internet okay and
fast fast in the food enough for me to
stream yeah and then they sent me a
contract though so it's $1,500 a month
what from Marion years four three three
years you have to sign my held up like
this but then this person I was working
with was they I went ahead and sign that
and sent it out for you I'm like what do
you mean so then I'm like oh I didn't
sign this and then they're like oh yeah
you did I'm like no I did
so like I'd have to take oh my cost
$250,000 so I'm bummed so I'm spending
all this money on Internet and it's
barely faster than you are
oh my god and I don't even using ever
I've never used it that's cause it's the
worst anyways it's fine the hashtag and
I said okay money for my game yeah
exactly
it's I'm dude it's been a gentleman for
two years it's almost a lie is it so
hard I feel like it's it that all that
stuff is so complicated it shouldn't be
that hard won't just get like cable and
internet no
yeah I think it's so difficult in Los
Angeles you know they just don't realize
or somewhere they don't want it to be
fast enough so then you'd have to try to
keep us gamers down yeah yeah cuz they
want you know Sweden it's like hi we're
fast I know and Sweden it's like three
right it's free they're like everyone
gets it and it's fast I was just over
there a couple weeks ago and first time
I don't know why I came back was it your
first time there I've never been there
how was did you go any Hot Springs
everyone was hot did you gonna eat like
spring around like rabbit I didn't go to
have everyone over there's beautiful
right yeah it's weird
why is that because the only like
carrots and fish or something no I don't
know I think it's just cuz there's all
what do they eat cuz it's all use it for
language that's what it is how does like
that it's all Swedish meatballs they're
just all eating Swedish meatballs yeah I
sitting on IKEA couches and they're
putting in their beautiful yeah burn
calories yeah keep going I hear you get
lost for hours job and they're skinny
exactly you're sitting back that's how I
have you but the point is these people
are sweet they're so nice everybody's so
helpful and everyone was free internet
and they exactly is the Internet yep so
they're happy all the time because
they're on the Internet exactly a lot of
people outside actually I don't know
they haven't found out that free
internet yet Oh cog nerd wait cog narara
in Slippery so he said it's not free but
a hundred hundred whoa
that's crazy that's what mine is it's
fifteen hundred is a hundred on it
that's bananas crazy all right now we
got the full games or get the [ __ ] your
princess is in another castle how am I
remembering [ __ ] what are so your
favorite game what are you what are some
your favorite games I really love all
time of all time any system oh man last
war song yes probably my favorite game
ever which is on Genesis you probably
haven't played huh what is it war song
no it's freaking old I should play it
I'm I've never played on my Jam's that's
so fun I got it for Christmas my parents
hid it in my Christmas tree it was I
didn't think I had gotten it maybe that
was part of it like the the build-up to
it yeah so I found it in my treatment
well you got it go fullscreen yeah it
was awesome
that's crazy it's this 2d game or love
about but what do you mean blah blah
blah a 2-d game I don't know how to even
in second whatever it's just I don't
know how to describe it in a way that
would make any sense
want to compare it to but it's like I
mean there's turn-based like I was just
a kid and I just thought it's the
coolest thing in the world if I played
it out probably would be let down that's
the thing it's like I feel like when you
play as a kid yeah like though that's
what you're that sure everything else
against yeah there's you know like six
things exactly you know like six things
and then the seventh is like why do some
your favorite games right now that
you're playing really like I mean
besides mine the diet looked fear oh
that's right if you're just joining us
Toby Turner and I'm in the Train free
very frustrating painfully iOS
destructive anyways it's a it's fun it's
a funny it's not painful I'm very much
still in my story this fear is an
amazing game
a first-person shooter so and they have
three of them but like they freakin I
mean the first I got so scared cuz
you're crawling in this event and
there's this like little girls black
hair obviously who's yet always yelling
at you I don't yeah a little ring ish
yeah yeah very very very ring issue I
had to pause the game cuz it's just
terrifying
is that true do you get scared easy I
don't know baby how do you have that
awesome animation I don't know you guys
have a board oh yeah oh yeah door closes
it's awesome stephen smith made all that
stuff i mean i stole mine from a Video
Copilot
that's cool yeah Stephen Smith the man
man of the hour made that for us and the
Jason O'Malley the creeper is our guy
who set all this stuff up I love it hey
you cut up green shirt guy it's a good
so you its mess it's Magda meth so we're
on met today coke is so Eden's why is
that one sparkling ah because here's the
thing
so this game's helped me rewind stuff
and go on it's all about time do you
have an encore our game or are we
getting this is an on trial again this
is you unlocked it or not we this is
yeah this is not right this is the full
one this is the full yes pretty good but
uh but so the deal is the green stuff
doesn't rewind so this game is all about
this game here's what I love this game
it's all about regret and heartbreak
yeah right it gets in there it gets in
there right into your soul right that's
why I love it yeah exactly this guy you
know our little man right here did it
thing and don't let the prettiness
deceive you there is oh the game itself
yeah it's very it's a dirty to do he
murdered something you don't know you
don't know he did bow the kid from my
boat I don't know it's very it's very
simple borrowed from that yeah I love
limbo by this what how the game play for
us I was my favorite games limbo is
amazing oh you guys can't see what he's
doing
yeah can't see what I'm doing he's doing
something but it's too amazing for the
internet and friendly but so if this
games all about time and rewinding time
and so the idea time which is currently
frozen but is that currently frozen
yeah so the stuff that's green isn't
affected by your rewind powers you know
what I'm saying
right so when I rewind this see how it
spreads these are gone what does that be
can you die from those no no but so you
jump on them but then we're trying to
get them apart sand we can I see like
that
okay see I mean it's a little puzzle
game where you yes scared of dying but
yeah they're all the this game is all
about puzzles but so the idea is it's
all about like regret like you've done
something bad so you're trying to kind
of rewind time to get this girl to like
E which is I can connect is it gonna
work you think uh well the end of this
game is phenomenal I don't rue it you
should play this game I don't are you
like a tiny miniature tiny person yeah
you're a tiny little guy this game is
yeah she's normal-sized and you're
trying to get Jonathan said team Pogo
can t touch Toby's hair for me please oh
yeah go for it yeah that's fine did you
get up mm-hmm I knew when he was touched
in Jack
you
oh I don't know what's happening no one
knows I think my vision is lagged
exactly my visions audio God I don't
know just look like we're waving this is
great its how so favorite favorite game
right now fear
they're scary get you one of my I
actually I haven't even played the
second one I don't know why it's like
it's good in the third one I wasn't it
wasn't a fan really yeah what's that
saying yeah you'd figured up in the air
was it wasn't so great I liked it I'm
just gonna get you past here and then
we're gonna go I mean you know you know
I don't I mean you're in time to do it's
hardly through this hand talk I will say
of course it's a little it's a little
hard to do nice
but I haven't I didn't play the second
one and I heard that maybe if it wasn't
as good or something maybe I yes I
wasn't such a big fan of infinite I
can't the first one either I played it
like halfway through and then I just
yeah had stuff to do
I don't know first one made me really
scared because I've said this before
everybody used to play with wireless
headphones and I was playing like late
at night and then here we go let's play
late at night and then I forgot that
they were on and I went to the kitchen
is a girl okay that's great alright
that's good that's great alright so here
we can play with wireless that once
again I agree I just play yeah with them
on here how do I freeze
all right so an extra whines time the
stuff that's green won't be affected by
the rewind okay so why did I just flip
that switch so I think as you want it so
you want to get the key I want it I
think you want to go oh and then go and
then oh I should go got it cool I think
so yeah when you were one stuff you'll
realize it's gonna be really
embarrassing for you guys to watch not
at all couldn't be more embarrassed just
expect this am I gonna be good anything
that you watch is knocking there's no
talent intensity Jones I'm getting you a
console today ps4 Xbox one you've which
one you prefer I mean I I just do like
PC really ICC PC master-race people of
YouTube but but I guess I've been
playing xbox more but I'd said that I'm
like oh I love it I cuz it drives me
crazy but you know it's probably good as
United what I'm doing so I think you
want to go down and hit the switch look
the thing
okay and jump and jump jump down and
grab the thing dude okay the piece go up
and then jump where do I hit the sweat
and then run try to hit the sweat oh
yeah wait oh no there's no way wait how
do you Oh God wait I think you want to
try every will uh okay so I have never
never played this at all hold on so
rewinding it just reminds everything
okay what about this what about this
ready what about this I would say go
down here's what here what about this
what about this go instead of going down
the ladder jump down huh right hit the
switch but what why do i jet what is
that gonna do because I think why would
jumping down James because wait watch
watch the hits which now hit X okay oh
wait hold on that meat over yeah it's
gonna leave on you Joe Matt yeah that's
what not flipping switch oh okay say cuz
the green
see the green effect and now yeah I
could stop oh the green cuz it's a
degree see I'm saying this game is a
mind that's really cool side Rumble yeah
yeah jump across the thing try jumping
across the thing yeah yeah and now
rewind now rewind but it won't I'm
getting cuz it's great because it's
green okay and then you're back up there
we go and now I do the switch again a
guy dude
see this game crazy I like that it gets
bananas that gets bananas I love banana
less than hanging okay so I never I
wouldn't have figured that out I think
what kind of PC ready play got a PC like
wait for people yeah what kind of books
your gaming rig what's your gaming rig
it's kind of old I'm kind of old what do
you mean I mean it well I have about two
years yeah but it's it's it's good I
mean it's like a you know tanks gonna
gtx 570 i think what is that everything
i don't know i don't know i co just put
some letters and as the numbers of dead
hey brainy i know me laney little buddy
oh my god
oh look at the bunnies why he hasn't I
seen a whole strong God their date the
dangerous can you die in this really
where our water war walkouts what's your
favorite fruit oh man oh geez okay water
Bowser do you guys really want to know
what you know we'll go apples bananas
watermelons not I love watermelon it's
so good and it's
sheets every time it's but is that a
fruit or yeah it is verse I think so
well not only it's a vegetable it might
be a nut it might be a nut actually come
on that seemed unfair
there's always murders plants coming out
of tubes and air all over the world
in-game Zabriskie bead uh can you do a
shout out for me Toby to Brendon Hall
shout out to Brendan hall an actual show
actually endorse out exactly I don't
know what is false
exactly this is a bunch I'm still I'm
bones these bunny rabbits are not gonna
oh my god you ever be so you die for
real nothing out there for the meteors
Jen doesn't leave flaming boogers to me
yeah they do that scared of bananas
scared of bananas somebody said to Z man
man this won't hurt you I mean unless
somebody you might leave you scarred may
be exactly early in life yeah that's
what it happens to banana problems okay
your pings ami why is there not some
cute redhead her opinion yeah what's
your opinion what's your opinion what's
your opinion on fruits
wow you got I liked repairs told you
they're nice and soft what are you
supposed to okay you can jump off ladder
can you uh I don't have any idea are you
doing on the bottom can you can't just
well I'm all better
you can't hop off the ladder do we need
to go back to it maybe there's something
we can do with the cannon do we go back
to the cannon and then stop it let's
just see well yeah I can't go there
obviously okay
go all the way back to the cannon do you
play League of Legends Dragon Warrior I
tried playing League of Legends I just
until those games that if you're not
good at it it really lets people down
make everybody just feel bad but you
have to stay in the game I mean I wanna
I just don't have any idea what I'm
doing right I don't know what's
happening here so right now I'm not sure
how we can Oh cuz if you were white it's
not gonna stop the kidney Jacques hébert
once you have to like reload sometimes I
don't know okay so that's problem okay
we're gonna get through maybe I'll
really get this a jump on top of the
rock yeah yeah
can you Joe uh-oh can't rewind it
maybe no it's possible we might not be
able to maybe we should scar to the next
no we will
do you think so no no Joe you know what
I think you can if you run right after
if you run right after it oh good god
there we go go go go go go go that's so
close right though you're real close I
bet you're once a while every once in a
while there's a big enough space yeah
every once in a while you gotta go one
two three four five six
[Applause]
there's no way what's that freeze time
so cannon shoots the fireballs freeze
time how do you freeze time
oh you know what oh oh I gotta get a
line of up Scott I don't like the other
ha so Sam sir lovey Meeks is very happy
that's you yeah they love you yeah come
back I say go back go back - I'll go
back sell them all right
so am i - queuing Fillion someone
mention I love ducks oh you love duck is
there something special about ducks are
you uh what's not serious Oh doo-dah
this is an obvious solution you're so
close yeah every other one now will be
nice
thank you thanks Chad Thank You Chad you
guys have Ramon oh that's beautiful
what's your favorite thing about it is
it the is it the feathers is the bill to
be able to go underwater and be like hi
suck for you Bobby
the webbed feet are pretty cool god oh
god wait what happened to us
what feed is kind of that's kind of a
thing I'm sure people are into that
sometimes
oh no wait you reverse sighs what
happened oh are you onion that you want
to sink that you don't sink tank fire
bone you come by your bone got time is
the thing that continues to happen no
matter where you are the level exactly
there are there we go nice Wow suited
failure well done
all right you child there we go are you
child please don't got this you cannot
gonna back it up Megan you got this
you're good there you go you're good
you're good you're good Oh nailed it and
record low Tom also sorry I'm doing
tingles we do take up this time Oh ed
you killing us you just kill me with it
sorry oh it's fine now it's this poor
guy this poor guy if you're this
character what a hell you leave hide is
over and oh okay we did it right or no
Thank You Howard Lee with Thane thank
you do it thank you do it well you're
not li irreversible yeah we'll see about
that I guess won't we yeah we'll just
have to see about yeah wait what can you
ghosts rabbits are freaking me out man
there's a beaut
anything you know what's kind of scary
to me like names that are cute that then
turned evil yeah no like children oh
yeah yeah yeah like chilling up children
with old man faces oh thanks scary yeah
that's weird that's yes I'm supposed to
happen isn't that weird that's my
competing or evil children old people
have all the evil life built into them
lazy busy 1:20 Aaron what games would
you want Connor to play person oh well
you're on a [ __ ] I just die anything any
any game he would play personally it
would make me happy because that would
mean he's less terrible wait what
happened what happened you know what I
look away from the screen for once for
once effing bad nothing bad now
everything's destroyed nothing bad
happened everything's just I needed a
new hit button this guy's just like
crazy he's got a beak I don't know how
you got this you got this more of this
frustration on my channel tobyGames AG
the children of scary Kenton 900s okay I
don't know I didn't see any button what
went up and what went down
Oh children are super scary chosen kind
of freaked me out I don't mean to be
though no well that's what makes them
scary they don't tell himself yeah their
own path there we go maybe well here we
go there's a key balls balls buddy come
on the goomers got left you could jump
on them it's kind of clapping for me for
not dying back with his mouth well done
well suited fool okay yeah now more
fantastic okay guys some time now that's
not good wait a second there's no way
I'll have you got away like
that's hilarious that's ridiculous it's
a puzzle game the blocking plant farm
can't be rewound you have to reset the
whole area to get that one puzzle what
do you mean what do you mean oh we might
have to go back oh that's what can be
done if we go back out of the hole and
go back in I bone myself yeah
no these guys you okay so I'm gonna lead
them over healers are terrible yeah and
then wait a little bit as a fall - its
death that's like you guys synchronize
just yeah that was crazy like a Lear I
mean the Terri Weedon audience I found
this very easy to go up with thank you
that was definitely you get up there oh
yes that's who falls for I think we have
to go back out and go out get back out I
can't go up here nothing on your right
that's what someone was saying you have
to go back out I everyone I don't trust
anyone I don't trust anyone and I trust
everyone
oh my god I do I trust them oh my gosh
god say hi to Tobey for me I'm gonna
back it out dog
thanks guys thank God he's gone
what are some other were some YouTube
channels you like to watch i or your
mouse or your lens jacksFilms is Jack
Sims Sean klutz nur is also wonderful
very talented how did you how did you
hook up with other youtubers do they
contact you do you contact us do you not
contact anywhere yeah are usually namizo
enemies do you kill each other here yeah
but we have to act like we're not okay
we have a show we have a show that we're
doing actually next next it's kind of a
behind the scenes of like a YouTube like
life of a person who does YouTube well
that's cool it's so funny I mean I I
think I'm writing it so hopefully it's
like that's like 300 minutes it's like
wait go back go back
yeah you take over I thought we had to
go back to this one no I think we just I
think we just have to go out the door
and back in okay cool good thank you for
steering me no problem wait so explain
what what's the thing you're ready it's
like what's like a funny it's It's
Always Sunny kind of thing meets flight
of the conchords Oh awesome a lot a lot
of songs in it that's great it's it's
pretty we're actually having meetings
about that half of this finalizing
everything but we're going to production
next month so oh that's how it has to be
good or if my career is over
no pressure yeah it's gonna be
just you know oh but it goes over that
like all youtubers like we're also just
nice it to it each other's faces and
they're like yeah like I think she's the
bad whatever it's just horrible battles
behind them it's not really like that
but yeah because everyone you know is
they worked so hard to build themselves
up and know for sure I'm very humble
I believe it yeah most of them because
well because also jacksFilms they all
have been except for Jax bill they'll
appreciate their everybody works hard
everyone does their you know what I'm
saying like so terms of that it's like
everyone is trying to do their best
I don't know how I'm gonna get that
piece over there how does that work oh
you jump on Messi Falls of death jump on
him as he falls to his death that's what
the thing was yeah and what I don't know
something me neither I just was
repeating wait he so what am I trying to
do so that green thing if you could push
it over how do I push it over you have
no idea down bub mmm I don't have a clue
what do you guys we a thing I see fault
I'd say fall sweetie yeah
ducks do rock do you guys oh man okay
I'm gonna follow this dude down is it
look jerky for them or no it's little
jerky I don't know is it sure I don't
look jerky i amateur he jerk like jerk
like careful like you did you are you in
close feel good about this good about
what do you guys think about what we're
doing I don't know give up this off we
need to get up there without rewinding
get up where I need to get up here
without rewinding kind of we're without
rewinding Gavin time man
Gambon time whoa that's a cool name I
like that how do you uh what was your
first Internet handle you know oh wow I
was Rasta no Rasta master t JT are you
really into like no I decided you know I
wanted the Rasta
I was like maybe I'm gonna switch gears
and get into that I love it that's
awesome - really interesting quite I've
never even thought of I haven't thought
of that name every wall I know cuz
everybody's so embarrassed cuz it was I
mean I never had a number anywhere oh
that's good so now you that's it that's
actually pretty good I know right you
know immediately that numbers are that's
weird
yeah I want to do anything to avoid that
yeah but it's difficult now it's really
difficult yeah yeah although now people
can tend to be original
people I feel like use their own names
along like before there is dude there's
more than one
Jana Turner not to us oh yeah he's dead
he's a famous bull rider Oh baby did you
ever get mistaken for bull rider Toby
Turner
I mean /i ever wonder what yeah if you
ever wanna waste in Hollywood sometimes
ride the bull but not well but then I
say I'm Toby Turner and maybe they'll
think who knows he had I okay so he had
a bunch of press about him and he didn't
have the website so I'm like now
building a website and on Toby Turner
calm he says the best Toby Turner the
world that's awesome that purple link to
Toby Turner calm oh yeah 1997 yeah just
skip this part I can't figure this out
yeah skip it and go to the main figure
yeah first game ever played I mean I'm
sure it was like some sort of Mario
situation I think we got we got a
Nintendo Co ordinate what's a bonk bonk
oh my god
turbografx-16 loves it yeah oh I haven't
heard that name in a long time he played
it recently no you should play it it's
still awesome
really it's so hot for the people who
don't know it will explain it's a kid
with it it's this yeah just baby with a
giant giant head I did a baby caveman
yeah and you run around like smacking
things with your face that's so cool
like oh dude you have to play it and
then uh I mean it's just it's so weird
but it's very fun and simple yeah turtle
graphics head like what are the enemies
in that game yeah dinosaurs a lot of
dinosaurs yet you would jump in the air
smack a pterodactyl in the face with
your face
killing him doctor should have been in
Jurassic world of core of a V with a
Chris Pratt please a giant baby the huge
a dude I like that that was fun yeah
yeah he was fun I did a I did a literal
so I do literal trailers writing one
half
and trailers I did one for Jurassic
world and all you have to go down and
all the way the left out for these guys
all the way the left isn't a waste until
they hop over T and then rush right over
but I did a literal about the about the
bunk and the Lego game bunk is so good
dude is so good it's good but what I
remember I just keep going back board
bonk and Chris Pratt but there's this
whole scene where it looks like like I
take it looks like they say something
different like like what is it called
oh yeah like that like you know but
they're pretty bad so I can't
incorporate those sometimes in the
little trick just because of people King
and I'm singing I'm like oh I need
something in there to put some fabric
that's all that guy's so freaking
talented but it looks like you saying
dinosaurs are stupid they look perfect
that's funny I like my job you have cool
job ID you have a cool job very lucky
very lucky to have this job used to work
at Kmart which was less exciting that's
cool too stocking fishing lures at 8:00
in the morning
7c look more diverse like I don't know
anymore the worst I only know what
morning looks like when I'm up all night
hey and I see it that oh yes I'm up haha
screw you
discreet I don't know they I think we
must hop the wrong way just murdered I'm
just going I'm keep oh really quitting
guys reversed to sit hey Benetton one
verse to get the key back first to get
the key back I do weird bone do I need
the key oh yeah let's just try oh my god
these rabbits dude yeah what is up man
you know they're look they're cute
bunnies and they have a cute flower just
come on their back like they have a hard
life ah so what so what that Aaron's job
is the nuts I didn't is that a good
thing or a bad thing yeah it's a
paranoid where was he was in fellas
we're go see ha ha Oh watch it
ha ha grab and die oh you can't come in
a jump Oh get a run right out and
immediately there we go nope no most so
close did I get to keep my three printed
head yes I have to keep it it's it's
wonderful what if I lose the real one
what wait what do you tire I have a 3d
printed head of my own
really they printed it out in Sweden
whoa that's awesome do that sweet is it
is it full-size yeah or yep it's awesome
it's cool and uh so they did that she's
very odd it's to promote this headphone
company okay and so like they printed
out all these all these severed heads
and had us trace around a race track
that's awesome yeah it was fun
it was so weird and ridiculous but free
trip to Sweden yeah and I get a free
severed head of my own so that's how I
sit in places are you are you defeating
him yeah I have you beat this kid uh
yeah it's great but I haven't played it
since like it came out you should play
bonk on this oh my god pong could be
amazing
do that see you guys every week you do a
stream everybody get your stream yeah
it's great it's very very fun yeah
people are great we stream on both
twitch and YouTube for you that's
amazing
oh god you guys handle stuff and your
sports Jason O'Malley I'm creeper
creeper kills it we're uh can you set up
my setup please Jason yeah it's really
helped everyone the world
O'Malley needs to just yes start
counting is like coming to people's
homes that would be very circles my my
house is a pit do you this is what I
don't know are you like leaning up today
oh don't do it
do you ever now do you shoot a lot of
stuff from your house yeah see that's so
my house ends up being basically just a
set yeah you know like that's the thing
is like there's stuff there like for
like three months my living room where I
spend 90% of my time was a Hawaiian
backyard that's a major s forever it's
just there forever I get sick of it yeah
now what is it well now it's now it's a
mix of like a weird like alleyway with
graffiti and then like all the furniture
pushed over to one side so it's like why
is that what are you shooting your house
I shoot a lot of weird things in my
house II how to word things mouth but
that's the thing it's like when you live
alone and you do a lot of videos you're
just like oh yeah let's just put this in
here you know what I'm saying and it's
just like
boxes and crap everywhere and just like
yeah I mean kinda like living in a
really crappy movie set you know yeah
and you know that's fine because you can
have a crab you send me a great movie
yeah so I have a puppet show posted it
ever whoa awesome this is awesome
it's so cool so I have this like puppet
set that's just kind of up against the
wall and it looks amazing but like so
it's even worse so I haven't even
released it and you know cuz I'm gonna
get a couple episodes course yeah
definitely and and so it's sitting there
I will will people think you're just
doing it for your own good I want to do
that want to find someone else that
would have the whatever set up in their
studio absolutely so I can have a house
bill oh yeah exactly
adults instead of way here's my green
screen set hey uh
like hey can I use your bathroom yeah I
just push the green screen I push it ten
stacked Lego boxes out of the way you
have to have the Builder I get in
trouble somebody asked if you ever have
you ever punched your a 3d printed head
and not yeah it is I have never happened
really involved yeah have you now you
should there's still time
I do love yeah it's just like if anybody
broke into my house they'd just be like
this person is either a murderer or
where should I go what do you think I
should go I think this is so pretty this
game is gorgeous doesn't matter where
you go look at this guy I'm not gonna
give him more he's just he's not saying
I think you'll be great and if the demo
dies you'll be great at VOE say you got
good do you have some voices you got
some different we can do quite a couple
voices that's perfect so that's I can do
that's a great voice oh you know we
watch some how much show about what is
there an Irish guy in the puppet show
Scottish Scottish I'm sorry I'm so I
apologize all there isn't but there will
be so actually there is a Scottish of
Scottish wizard hunter you're are you
are obsessed with wizard yeah yeah well
I got to keep the their magical their
magical the bread
we also have like a movie they go
without wizards oh my god of course
that's a script now but I think we're
making it next year
interesting yeah and you're a wizard
like what what kind of a what you as a
wizard what would your specialty would
you mean ice wizard asking spells by
singing songs a musical wizard I love it
that's pretty tight flute how do you do
it my mouth a flute your mouth
no no I'd have other people in my in my
wizard band yeah oh there's a whole
wizard family maybe they would play
instruments that would be the lead
vocals whoa that's pretty tight lead
vocalist in it boys back up I mean I
don't know you know it depends watch it
you're humble you're humble me yeah but
I wouldn't steal the spotlight from the
lead yeah well of course everyone knows
yeah where the talent is yeah talent is
yeah and I would make him play the
guitar so you'd be tough to focus right
focus I just got vocals I mean I can
play guitar also very well but I mean
you know I don't do that
what's a skill you wish you had the
dough besides actually they don't have
sides casting spells which is more that
would be that's not a skill let me call
you guys yeah does the amazing school
dude I don't focus that I have so much
every night you get stuff done you made
you're just joining us chumpy Turner
mind the diamond go down by the diet of
the game that is out now for free iOS
store that's right i'll but i didn't i
didn't code that if i had a code
together okay so I see what you're
saying right so I got a book deal
I'd write three books congratulations
Thank You senator a book three and never
in three is so many yeah yes so it's I
think it's done but now we're like
illustrating it it's like a it's not
like a real meaningful heart play like
thing it's funny but it's not like well
things that are funny can be meaningful
and I'm Yours you Forrest Gump
so I hide a lot there's a lot of fun
stuff in it but it's not like you know
me being like you know we I got a write
up thing work you know if you tried to
write a book and know hey that no it can
never write it by it's too long but so
so long no no one responds or more than
write pages yeah I can do it painfully
I'd be a great pamphlet writer so I
couldn't make a fan or a flyer I think
okay so
people make advances liars and put those
around my shirt they complete them so I
can do something like that sure like a
small little project yeah a small shirt
so so for songs like I write the vocals
I sing the vocals and then I'm like and
then I leave them on my computer because
I mean oh I'll go do the guitar later
but I have to plug stuff in and he has a
hole and then I never do it so that I
send it off to my friend who makes the
makes the guitar and the drum sometimes
terabrite very talented oh terabrite
would they did I think the couple they
won a contest that we're on our show
oh really right is that terabrite that's
awesome it's a buddy's the corner oh
yeah it's a guy in a girl right J yeah
yeah yeah they did a thing where I'm
meeting yeah for awesome yes or
Valentine's Day they came and ate all of
dinner on our set that's fantastic it
was insane yeah well I'm going to call
him out oh my god please yes tell him
you said hello
hope they're doing wait so there oh so
they do the music for you yeah dude it
is a small the other day that's kind of
a small world it is what I'm working
with him forever
Oh God so yeah I just don't how did you
God you guys meet I mean like maybe like
four years ago
like so so you meet at the conventions
right where everybody does YouTube stuff
and got it you know we just got along
and he's is bright really towels I'm
like you I want to make him play on
stage yeah cuz he's so good but he
hasn't really done it so my getting to
it's no stress he's more of a studio I
known yeah studio musician but so like
he you know I'm trying to trick him into
it cuz actually I tried to check it yeah
because it's not it's not so bad where
you're like yeah yeah let's all meet at
Danny Denny no stage okay okay just
stand here
no ah but so like even if it sucks it's
just comedy music right now so right it
can still be funny in and not be good so
you doesn't have to stress because when
I go onstage I'm everyone knows it's
gonna be kind of terrible really I don't
know but they know I'm gonna win I'm
gonna not know my words as well as an
actor that could be enjoyable that's a
worst-case scenario it's fun
alright you know and so I love doing
that stuff and just embracing that you
know it's not gonna be perfect yeah
exactly bracing the magic of the moment
yeah yeah but it's gonna be a bomb we're
gonna have it's gonna be a moment for
sure
b-bomb and we're gonna enjoy that yes
going to be a moment for sure somebody
asks what are you succeeding uh I don't
know I mean to find you seeing yeah some
stuff you have to come back yeah I think
so I have to get you have to go back and
forth a lot it oh no I had it
wait that's kind of like from the 90s
right yeah yeah I just was thinking
about my favorite games ever and that's
probably my favorite game ever
that game is super fun you haven't never
played it no but I hear it because it's
no because people say it's a hole that
I'm trying to concentrate I do this well
because it's not a precursor to Final
Fantasy Ram I made notes Ultima Online
was like part of it you love my default
is positivity yeah true yeah that's
right that's right my default is uh and
then I you know miss deadlines but it's
awesome online they roll RPG yes wasn't
one of the first mm or Jesus or been
making it up okay yep I was right here
it's super fun it was amazing it was
amazing but but it was just so much
better like I played some of the mmo's
now and you can't do anywhere near as
much stuff as you could in this so those
you're saying it people will their stuff
all of their stuff and you can't do that
now because people have stuff it's
binding down equip or buying picked up
or whatever
what about like EVE Online know that you
could kill people okay take their ships
and stuff oh you okay yeah I'm into the
medieval that the space you're to the
wizard stuff was there magic wizard
Skyrim you ever place Chiron of course
have you played the Skyrim the Elder
Scrolls online no I did I here's why I
can't play now geez I've said this
before but you'll never do anything else
you yeah you can't miss a moment you
can't smoke half a crack rock you know
I'm saying like you're I'm eating and
wasteful it's yeah it's a good way to
eat with everyone else it's just
fiscally irresponsible you know to only
smoke half your crack but uh but that's
like taken out of context it's okay mom
if you're just now starting to watch
yeah I'm sorry I'm sorry for everything
yeah okay again half the crack rock I
can't do a calf a cracker I mean yes so
Dino I would just that's all I would do
nine months I did nothing else okay
here's what exactly that would be me
I've always loved Blizzard cuz like
they're so they
funny like the joke all it's on and they
do a lot of voices like that's kinda
what inspired me to do all my friggin
some of my game
love the song vomits yeah and so and I
do play Warcraft 1 like back in there ah
like I played the very first Warcraft so
probably one yeah but that wasn't online
or you know the one here yeah like yeah
low quality like deities yeah oh yeah um
a disc oh yeah for shows awesome so like
that's that's kind of what I got into in
the beginning blizzard games and then I
got I got that I did I had to put warp
in me too that I had of the World of
Warcraft this is Blizzard oh yeah I
gotta flow with the other stuff then I
played what was it
Red Alert conquer conquer that might
have been like the last one of it cuz I
I almost like failed out of school I was
playing that game so much so in a lot of
my classes I was in the gifted program
so well well well we had educational
wizard yes bad computers that work dude
I think songs that teach you stuff that
is kind of like magic totally if you've
learned something from a song and you'll
never forget the lyrics I totally agree
so I have a song that's like teach you
how to play guitar chords' the chords
are the are the letters that I sang okay
it goes you play it it's like hey I can
see your deep I can see our TV yes if
you see a minor with double D's don't if
a minor what it's good Wow has to be a
that's great that's great that's great
but if you'll be used to high anyways
dude that's amazing
anything goes on but so you play it and
then like if you learn that song you
know the corner tenacious d bit one guy
you have to be your bull is he not okay
I get these two tables eken and k the
second person that's just you know no I
don't think I know you dye your soul
your one man red I can't focus
oh that's true you know what you need is
like an accountant you need like a mr.
yeah adderall don't like yeah exactly
exactly don't know an is just solid real
world advice Frank
a won't you be my effing but voice is
gone my voice is gone I'm very talented
my voice is gone just know that it
sounds good usually it's in person is
incredible oh yeah yeah it's the
compression yeah we were screaming after
the premiere party we went to the it was
fun wait Saturn air Genesis yeah was
amazing really that's awesome and and
what's your other what's your second
favorite Terminator movie you have to
sign me you 92 I mean yes we're gonna
get into a fight it we're gonna say to
you okay so I just watch all of them of
course cuz Loki did a marathon right
yeah so uh yeah I mean one and two are
amazing so one is amazing and very
simple right Oh simple dish I mean now
here's the bacon term it's my question
but she's still brilliantly so brilliant
but here's my question why would the
terminators send why don't they try to
kill Sarah Connor because gonna be able
to answer whether gonna ask well without
her
the term Ayers wouldn't exist right no
no
so they touch on that in the new and the
new one right wait the last one was what
the last one was the one with Christian
Bale which was dope right awesome was
Christian Bale am I making that it no
Dawson was yet wait that was maybe I
didn't see that one they want me to see
I'm warning you no no no one with
Christian Bale where he's like in the
future I never saw that one okay it was
cool it was good it was calling I just
watch I'm sorry I just watched the first
couple ones no problem and I I forgot
about that one I'm sure it was good
actually I heard it was great are you in
the same place yeah yeah I'm trying to
go back to get the other puzzle pieces
cuz we can't well how'd you do that how
do you go back news what because you can
go yeah yeah cuz you can go once you get
out of a door it'll eventually put you
into mmm I'm trying to get this little
puzzle piece we want to ask the chance
baby bunnies kill you they'll still kill
you dead they'll kill you dead so you
like the Chris Rose right I like that
one yeah I like I didn't like one showed
four I didn't like three yeah that's
right okay so I heard three was not good
so I actually also didn't I've never
watched that one and cuz I'm for some
reason I go buy everyone else's opinion
because I usually they're usually right
yeah I agree the group is just Christic
is probably
not film person thing to say but look I
don't want to watch it with me that's
not good so like I look online it's like
you know 20% not critics but human sure
sure it's like 80% human oh we love it
critics like oh it sucks it's gonna be
great
yeah it's great I'm sure what why you
know it's ridiculous but uh I don't know
and if it's a hundred percent positive
by critics it's usually like ah yeah
we're four minutes so usually a little
boring I always go by the user read
nothing like this has ever been made by
God mr. Lee er you need to reverse time
to get the Sheep along safely
wait what nothing wait I mean I think
with the thing here I think is I'm just
not supposed to rewind up idols
oh yeah you're in first of all oh um
this one I think if I just don't rewind
right I think I think so no no no wait
let me ask that question can you triple
job if I don't rewind here that top oh
my god Jesus ha ha this game makes me
insane but I don't remind but over
whined then that then the top part is
gonna go over right whoa do you know
what I'm saying go over and then like if
I don't rewind oh this goes over oh I
need to see well is the top perking
going to vodka just couple just keep
going right just go right I mean is it
gonna stop izumi green stop I don't I
don't know why don't die at all just
don't die yeah just be good it's so good
yeah not good we're good nice oh no no
no bro okay we're okay we're okay oh my
god oh we are we are real good or real
call my god no my dad yeah and he's
gonna get gray hair like your dad oh my
god is ridiculous
come on oh god alright see we're good
we're good look how good we are
look I heard we are you guys oh you were
yeah that was amazing so we're so it was
not a triple drop but yeah they realize
it was a don't rewind
you don't realize oh come on this is
seriously just oh no jump on the green
pipe
jump on the green right pipe their line
there's a platform Oh to jump up while
you're on the green pipe then there was
a winky face so jump up while you're on
the green pipe before the base comes
Irving I got it don't get off it stay on
it
do you work there's a mysterious thanks
for no help chat what is this mysterious
trap they helped in their way they did
they told us how to fix it they said
don't rewind that's it well good point
yeah and then I would win what do you
mean this game Oh kill you god oh my god
oh my god yes please take over take over
sorry the controllers will sweat yeah
I'm shorts that's why it's good it's
Toby Jub Jub last but Toby they got your
new app they got your new who-who Jubjub
last oh nice nice yeah play it and they
don't frustrate you do I do here
whoopee it's good yeah now you gotta put
the pieces together that's never a half
it is focus focus focus
they're leaving you what's up rotate oh
yeah I'll be an OB okay okay guys yeah
this is not gonna be easy for you guys
what is that is that no not at all no no
I don't have all the pieces no no no not
all of them but you can put the ones you
have together you know have to do what
if I don't put them together I mean you
could do it right now you can do it
later if you put them all together then
it becomes a block that you can jump on
oh that's useful exactly do I want to do
that right now
oh sweet t-shirt oh thanks guys that's
her tea I got an Ed Hardy shirt trying
to be cool what about for Toby Turner
well yeah well I like that we have
colorful things yeah and our shoes let's
show them again oh yeah we got some oh
I'm American flag yeah they're both very
the camel is very merry that's exactly
I'm done a very Miller so I'm I'm from
art are you military no my always been
famous military oh my family okay you
silly little you almost got it you
almost got it is that one supposed to do
here yeah you just jump across the Nuge
fall down and grab the key did it work
for you I did it did before
Oh Blair you little monkey none of mine
I don't
okay what's your favorite ice cream oh
no what whatever 100 green that's so
awesome
okay I'd like to have a little puzzle I
love it I like why you asked me about
ice cream you ice cream can you guys
just all high-five us through the power
of the Internet all right ready everyone
put their hands on the screen ready one
two three boom goes very slow you added
as actual slapping there we go you can
beat this guy believing you were a white
stop me a crazy and he won't rewind but
the things will you know what I'm saying
so when you rewind um it'll reset and
that's how you get it this is cool I'm
boned yeah come here buddy
Oh shady friend shout I bet I bet you
can do a pretty good impression of
Bobcat from police guy oh dude did I
sound like Adam omen to do it
all right there's no way he's gonna be
so embarrassing what does he say what's
like a line you would say uh I'm not
sure I mean she just does that like a
yeah it's painful it's cuz my voice is
does is are you happy now are you
planning on playing any what was it
happy times Beth happy wheels happy
wheels you gonna play any happy wheels
yes I'm gonna play some what is happy
will it's like you know what is it it's
amazing it's a slash game where you you
you ride around obstacle courses and try
to get to the finish line amazing
without without getting your rent your
limbs ripped off and you will inevitably
get your okay how do I make this the
life your life oh yeah yeah but it's so
uh it's you know it's just a simple
flash game but where you are it's very
gory in your limb that's awesome I love
that your your child will be just killed
and launch him into death traps
we're doing a cartoon with them actually
the guy that made a chimp and awesome
it's so reminder why I am oh my god you
did go I know go it's largely ever gonna
be in our be oh no that means oh nice oh
there we go
wow dude amazing good job you just like
sold Wow look at that
it's just set on the screen
I haven't played happy once I'm sorry
I'm sorry I'm sorry
you should what do you think makes a
good video game villain like that skinny
dudes pretty crazy-looking he's pretty
cool I would look for in a good video
game villain like a wizard like what
would be the evilest wizard you could
think of Wow
I think just somebody says harsh word
his eyes are cool-looking
oh he's oh yeah okay cool you know that
threatens your girlfriend oh yeah
definitely threatening the girl for how
you know it's on yeah yeah it's like
he's looking a layered way like a smarmy
a smarmy wizard yeah whoa can you can
you hit him over and over oh yeah oh
yeah oh yeah oh yeah no no stupid he
doesn't a wide member oh oh oh no I just
bunk okay oh you so close silly little
look at that's amazing the double jab
double tap come on baby come on baby
almost goddamn you just one more go to
sleep I swear paraffins says Toby bless
your face in case you sneeze during this
live stream at I missed it there you big
sneezer
thank you i bless everybody space just
inclusive just in case or unless the
face just in case just to Keith glad to
see it that's all you need we finished
it well Arnold actually Arnold blesses
bless my face of work you know before
killing Mike me as I was t1000 awesome
and he killed me by or put me into a
time vortex and then saved like living
human me yeah from being murdered by
this robot version who is pretending
being yes I told was it Candace what's
your face news like no so then later
those two 1000 me yeah he like you know
it's trying to trap yeah and then he
grabbed grabbed me and he was like bless
your face and awesome it's freaking cool
that's awesome wait is that when's that
out is that that's out now it's on on on
second foster loss bet hit him with a
link bless your face child bless your
face oh you silly little key grasping I
never thanked you for the face blessing
Lorna tanks
how did that start how do the plus your
Pfister so oh I don't know I have no
idea I just I think I said if you know
what is that happen I'm just gonna have
to say stuff and then uh if I wouldn't
say the next day you know people would
get a little letdown
yeah so they just continue to say
they're just kind of cuz you know what
all the people down no no you gotta get
what they want what they want
yeah but so I started doing that and I
kept doing little things that just
became my things and so I would say like
bless your fake ass off
I say piece off also he's off a piece
off galleon forty-four asks of us is
Wendy's Tobuscus adventures come out on
PC I think that's also Android first
yeah then they're gonna pour it over to
PC but it's not it's all very slow cuz
the the same company that saw like the
company that we're working with then
exists game mechanics also yeah okay so
I just they're
McCammon yeah it's just low it's very
slow yeah hit them to do because they
have a lot of stuff there they all type
like this they're like maybe they go
type like this hopefully before the end
of the year I mean it's yeah it works on
I mean it should work with our bugs
right so the books have to be fixed
otherwise everyone's you know you're
plating then these bugs parts of it yeah
and what am i doing
I think you're gonna go you're gonna go
up and jump on that platform and then
you're gonna go I do the key in the
thing and get the thing with okay I see
thank you not sure what happens there
I think oh you know what trying to
rewatch try to rewind rewind the try to
rewind cuz I think I think you got it I
think you got to go down really you
gotta go I think you gotta do a mega
rewind a super oh why oh why why why
because I think it's because they were
because there's a pit there's a puzzle
we're leaving a puzzle piece to give it
really made a puzzle piece I think got a
so rewind really I think yeah it's super
rewind okay but yeah and then back up to
pick tempo
yeah because then the platform will
still be there Sam saying we got to wait
for that whole thing to go up Oh like I
like your setup how this is great
well send O'Malley over listen oh my
lady please please all right all right
now wait and try for that splits
platform now go over it go over to the
right go over to the right
Dalen yeah get up there before that
thing goes down see on there oh [ __ ] we
need the key
Oh Sookie we want to get to keep fast
again yeah yeah yeah he fast get the key
fast yo where's that key other guys
uh-oh how do we get up jump so just be
faster just be faster then be fast and
talented you can do this believe me I
believe in you with the quickness bless
your face man - you got this how often
are you are you out here all the time
this you got this I don't we got ya all
the time I want to eat what what's that
well your dream play you were gonna
start streaming oh yeah I'll start
streaming at home you can come over to
sit in the alleyway yes oh yeah and
change the steps into game flapping with
the thing with this thing that that
thing oh I didn't see you Tom Oh God
the key is a revelant to get the peace
first we got to get up there to get the
key first
Oh God peace first piece you guys got
Lube head to pay for that you got eggs
guy team-ups who got a 24/7 stream would
be like a tag team do you want to squirt
Peruvian do want to have screw those
babies open do wanna have their babies
already hello I guess how many babies
how many babies do you are you talking
about I mean I don't know I understand I
which baby to do babies to work I need
help
yeah put those babies doing it hell you
can get babies to wash dishes yeah you
know babies got tiny low hand select
loop poop once oh yeah as a bio weapon
baby baby over the wall and pooping
everywhere
yeah yeah cos very delicate you just
wrap a baby in bubble wrap it wouldn't
be that expensive because it's a tiny
baby and ship it to your enemies they're
just poop because that's what yeah it's
a weapon to fire weapon this is why I
should never be a father
baby baby okay so I hate to be a
describe it if I'm back let's go back
now what it's good that's 100 this let's
go all the way to the left and then I
have to flip it and then run no oh yeah
I think you're I think I may take you
where I'm not that makes sense I think
it makes sense we'll find out oh and
then I do it this is gonna be
I'm actually really excited my sister
and a kid because at some point I can't
wait to put him into videos you don't
have saying like he's like a living prop
like my sister gave birth to a prop I'm
excited to give birth to a prompt
there's no way this is gonna work - you
- I'm stop freaking screwed there's no
way I love it okay hold on is there
another switch everything that I can
switch back I'm not sure good we could
just skip this whole area you keep going
forward yeah maybe this is that's what I
do when I run into problem in life to
move on I just move I know many my bank
accounts so what let's just move on
let's move on Oh episode I let this door
and then she'll read and power moving
platforms in real life
yes escalators escalators yeah how fun
is it you in a minute at airports yeah
Airport I mean that's why I usually have
Healy zones everything in the world is
moving oh my god do they make Healy's in
our size i yes oh my god the kind that I
have they they don't sell and they're
awesome I'm not wearing now which is
like are they so issues where are they
they're they look like Commerce whoa
that's crazy but they don't sell them I
don't know if it's because they don't
see more sigh conversely what about in
Europe and you're up the laws are way
more lacks and Sweden they all got he
leaves quite everywhere here's what in
my mind what I think about it when I
think of Sweden supermodels eating
meatballs from wearing Healy's that's
just like Sweden for that that's like I
should write travel books maybe that's
my side career that's all right sound
kind of nice yeah yeah I know I rewind
out holding key balls okay I'm just lord
re1 what what do you say are you guys
I'm I'm not sure they're trying to help
switch while it's on the right Oh hate
to switch wallets on the right hit the
switch once on the right are you guys
this room for Ari tomorrow you guys
drink tomorrow nope although at Comic
Con we're gonna stream everyday are you
down at County are you coming back on
yep nine to twelve oh my god that's
gonna be awesome
we're good let's see I'm a signal that's
all gonna be there with streaming every
day I could weave bananas okay so hey
the balls on the right and then run
around we might just down we might just
give up on this level it's 1:30 we might
just give up yeah we're gonna give up
Aaron just name three things popular
Japanese porn Healy's Sweden and
meatballs
what kind of Japanese that we watch is
that then your watches of seriously
weird Japanese boy I mean it's probably
behind some kind of password yeah
why you haven't seen you're on a list
you're definitely on a list yeah it's
clear clearly I step one for them I
think there's Toby what's your favorite
snack except a nugget in a biscuit of
course what can I say my favorite snack
no you can say except the one that's
your favorite sugar just straight sugar
bad guys sugar I'm boned what I'm doing
now is back at work
I thought okay I hate it walls on the
right right didn't even successfully
work it unsuccessfully works though I I
think we're gonna get I think we have to
give up we're gonna give up together
we're gonna make it a joint decision to
all of us yeah you know none of us are
losers individually individually as a
group we're not losers either yeah but
we're all kind of yeah you guys Toby
Turner thank you for coming to name
mailing his game mine the diamond and
and what else Damascus adventure wizards
yeah go yeah know what you have the
Wizards game that costs like five
dollars it's okay it's worth it but it's
a lot but it's got what is it it's
awesome it's got widget it's our game
it's really fun yeah yeah but watch the
germinator nature it's pretty awesome
watch terminator video and yeah
youtube.com slash Tobuscus and for the
games or Toby Turner or Toby Turner
where are you on - where you on Twitter
to be disagreeable skews so stupid just
tobuscus tobyturner it's all you and if
you like bull riders also - yeah exactly
rawski Jason O'Malley I mean see you
guys next Monday for Monday male I see
you later bye bye
you